I mean Joe Biden says he's Catholic too
right yeah but here's the thing Joe
Biden explicitly does things in public
that tell us otherwise
and he openly defies Church teaching
children
should transition uh get over because I
think he was addicted to something for
quite a while and then he came through
that like yeah like a bunch of problems
and then he went to rehab and actually
like put his life on a better track and
then that Catholic thing happened from
what I'm aware of yeah Joe Biden said he
was Catholic and his life just went on a
way worse track I'm Catholic abort your
baby buddy yeah exactly I'm Catholic but
I don't believe in the Catholic Church
you know wait uh minutes that's called
not being Catholic